I would say that Trump stands for a set
of principles that he won't back up from
and there's a lot of people that hate
those principles and we live in a
society where the media loves love's
love's loves selective journalism so
they go after him they misconstrue
things and he say purposefully
purposefully misconstrue stuff that he
says so do I think that it's about Trump
unifying I think it's about the media
dis unifying so it's about the medias
doing selective reporting in order to
divide America because if they divide
America now remember a lot of these news
media outlets are controlled by what
much larger corporations who are
controlled by what ideologues that are
sitting back there trying to use the
media as puppets why do 98 percent of
journalists why are they liberal okay
98 percent of journalists are registered
and I need a number of others yes cuz
that's pretty into if that's accurate
that's pretty sick what percentage of
journalists are liberals oh this is
gonna be really really really good we go
B but I opening for you Adam when you
realize everything is skewed not finally
true 58% of national journalist
financial journalist but so so do what
percentage of journalists are registered
Democrats okay so what percentages of
journalists are registered Democrats are
you ready for this mmm right there
Wikipedia I don't know if we so Chi is
gonna look I look that up and see if you
can find oh look look look look the
Washington Post just 7% of journalists
are Republican so 93 percent 93
forgettable I was up by 3% okay go up a
little bit yeah this is a scary number
ladies and gentlemen very very scary
number
wow just 7% of Republicans 7% 71 was 26%
so here's the question and this is a
general question do you need to have a
college degree
to be a journalist I think that every
citizen is a journalist okay but to be
like to get hired by a major publication
do you need to have a college degree no
you don't know you don't need to have a
college degree no you've got to be a
journalist a good writer so what what's
your but but I would say most of them
that get hired by you yes yes are 95%
Habbakuk you're working for The
Washington Post so what's your bill
what's your point
what percentage of Democrats or liberals
if you will have a college degree what
percentage of Republicans of a class
that yeah I'm so glad you asked that
because guess evil watch yes so what
else guess what else is controlled by
the Liberals higher education so if you
actually go back and study the
Rothschilds and the Rockefellers the one
thing that they said is this they said
if we could convince Americans that they
need more money to be happy then we can
convince them that they need a better
job to make more money and then if we
could convince them that that better job
they have to have a degree in order to
get it
then we'll guarantee that they have to
come through us in order to get the
degree to get the better job to get more
money and so what do they do and this is
like go go read the book killing Uncle
Sam okay and it breaks it down
specifically how the Rothschilds and
Rockefellers and all the people that are
in the 1% of 1% of 1% all of the people
that are behind the globalist agenda
they knew that they had to get people to
go through the educational system so
maybe a better Google search is what
percentage of professors and
institutions higher education are
liberal and you're going to literally
find out that when you go look there's a
reason that we have organizations like
turning-point and or in why because
there is an understanding that all of
that like you never see a college
protesting a liberal being on campus but
guess what you send a conservative there
and what do we get
ben shapiro goes to speak at a we get
riots Mylo yeah innopolis goes to speak
we get riots why because it's all
controlled by liberals and that I think
is the problem when you have journalism
in higher education these Institute
controlled by the liberal left then we
have a major issue so what's your point
with college while he's doing this
search what percentage of college
professors are Democrats
go ahead what's your problem what's your
because we might be actually agree and
we might be heading towards an agreement
for a second what are your thoughts on
having to go to college in order to
succeed right there click on I think
that that's absolute baloney okay so we
just agreed Democratic professors
outnumber all the guys 10 gosh 10 to 1
that's Washington times 10 to 1 what do
you think about that I think you know
something that I'm always going to
gravitate to while we do this podcast is
unifying our country and not being all
the way to the right like Josh are not
being all the way to the left like a
birdie so you I'm not all the way to the
left I'm center-left all right I'm
trying to bring people into the center
here so clearly if 10 people if 9 out of
10 what was the number 1001 10 Democrat
professors one Republican perfume it
would be great if that was a little
closer to 5050 6040 that'd be great
you
[Music]